hello how's it going today I wanted to
show you guys how to add sound to your
C++ projects using STL - mixer basically
just gonna walk through a little demo
that gets it up and going and I've just
done a Google search for a CL - mixer
here so this is a way that you can add
sound into parts of the logic of your
program even if it's a console program
you can do it but you would imagine that
this is more intended for games or other
sorts of applications which works great
for now STL - mixer can do a lot of
pretty cool things and we're just gonna
scratch the surface here in this first
video so I'm on Windows here and I'm
gonna be using Visual Studio of 2019
Community Edition if you want to follow
along I recommend you do the same it's
pretty straightforward so what you're
gonna need is the development libraries
and the VC Edition so I've already went
ahead and downloaded these these are
just zip files and I unpack them it's
just a folder inside so I'm not gonna
walk through that but basically you need
to download this in a unpack it and you
need to do the same thing with SDL to
just STL - this one here you're gonna
need the same development library for
STL - and then mixer is sort of an
add-on to STL so you will need both
those and you will need to unpack both
of them
these are pre-built for 32 and 64 we're
gonna be using the 64 alright so
assuming you have that sorted out
downloaded and unpack those somewhere
where you want to keep them we can
continue so we're gonna go ahead and do
a new project here on Visual Studio 2019
and we're just going to do an empty
project so we're gonna go ahead and hit
next and we'll name this sto - basic
sound demo there it goes and we got our
default setup my default might look a
little different than yours but mainly
you want to have a solution Explorer and
a place to run your application here I'm
gonna switch this to release in 64
because that's what I'm gonna be
intending to work with you right off the
bat and over here in my solution
Explorer I'm going to click show all
files and that way I can actually see my
project there's nothing here yet
so we're gonna create a few things we're
gonna just right click on the top level
here I'm gonna go to add new folder name
it I'm just going to name it SRC for
source and in here I'm going to add a
new item and yes the C++ file we're
gonna name it main.cpp
so it's our entry point and we're just
gonna go ahead and populate that with
some basics and then we're gonna add a
another new item and this time it's
going to be a class and it's going to be
well we can name it whatever we want
it's basically going to be a class for
our sound and this first one we're gonna
make is going to be intended for sound
effects so it'll be for short little
snippet sounds we'll call it STL to
sound effects sure we're not using any
base class or anything there we go let's
go ahead and just fill out a few starter
things public and private make sure
there's actually okay these didn't go
into the source folder so we're gonna go
ahead and drag them in so watch out for
that sometimes when you create in your
stuff it doesn't end up where you think
and listen I think if I right clicked on
this folder and did it it would have put
it in there but I might not have done
that okay so we've got a bit of a
skeleton here and now we just need to
put in all our code and link STL - I
know the codes more exciting than the
whole linking part
but the linking part is required so I
could show you all the code but the code
is not going to work until it's linked
so I might as well plow through the
linking part so basically what you want
to do here is where you unpacked those
first two files I was talking about from
from this here this development library
on SDL 2 and this SDL mixer development
library that's what we're looking at
I've unpacked those in a very special
folder
I called dev on my big SSD yeehaw I also
take note that I have a hard drive
specifically for one game arc because it
takes up an entire hard drive anyway
okay so this is where those are unpacked
STL 2 and STL mixer so I'm gonna look at
STL - I'm gonna go inside it you'll see
an include in a libraries folder and
you'll see the same thing on the mixer
and include in a libraries folder now
just to get started let's just go in
this order we're gonna go into the
library folder on SD l2 and then in 264
and then we're going to find this dll
and we're gonna copy it so ctrl C or
right click and copy however you want to
do it and I'm gonna move this and then
when I go back to your project and to
the top level and just hit paste and
then we want to do the same thing for
the other dll's so let me get back to
that folder here and we're gonna go all
the way back to the mixer go to the live
64-bit and you'll see a whole bunch of
stuff here you want to grab everything
but the library pretty much so copy all
of these files and then go to the top
level again here on your project and
paste them here or just paste artists
I'm purposely not using the hotkeys so
you can see exactly what's going on so
as you can see these have been added to
the project now yeah we're just going to
need those it's going to complain later
if we don't have those
and we're going to go to the next part
now where we are going to set up the
includes in the libraries so we're gonna
go over here to our solution Explorer
and click this properties button you can
also get to this in a couple other spots
I think notably under view maybe but I
always click this wrench because it's
easy to remember and find so if you
click the syringe it brings up the
properties for whatever you've clicked
on last I've clicked on sound effects LH
I want to click on this top level one
here and then click the properties
because this will give me my current
project properties so in here I'm going
to set up some V C++ directories so if
you double click on this one then you
find the include path here
VCC directories include directories
click the caret to the right click Edit
and then you want to click the new
folder up here click three little dots
to allow you to direct somewhere and
right now we are doing let me just
confirm here cancel cancel I'm doing the
includes so when this includes I want to
add the paths to those includes on both
those folders I was looking at in my big
SSD dev SDL to include so I just
highlight folder select folder I
actually I don't think that's good
enough let me edit this because let me
just double check no that's fine you
just click include and then hit OK then
you want to do this again and you just
want to point to your other one now it's
worth noting that you can actually make
these includes in libraries you can put
them in your project as well and then
link them in that way if someone else
downloads your project it'll just work
otherwise they're gonna go have to set
these up because their hard drive paths
are going to be different in yours
so I'm skipping that step of making it
part of the project and making it sort
of an outside thing that the user needs
to do but if you're on the same
development on live laptop um all the
time or computer all the time it's okay
to not necessarily put every duplicate
every development library with every
project because you listen up with a
million duplicates for every project but
when you go to push it the outside world
for the people to use that's when you
want to sort these out and put them with
your project
okay so side rant done about that I
guess it wasn't a rant it's actually
important information so let's go to the
libraries here and it's essentially the
same thing except these libraries are
slightly different and I'll explain so
we go to lives make sure you go to x64
because we want this 64 bit once go
ahead and apply that and we're gonna do
that this again except for the mixer
this time same thing same thing mixer
564 so if you're ever pushing this to
release or want someone else to use it
it would be a good idea to put these
libraries with your project and then
sort out these linkers so that they just
point to your project and whoever gets
it and downloads and opens it with
Visual Studio it'll just work and
they'll just be able to hit play ok so
those are all done and good we also need
to set up the linkers so the linkers for
this project or basically all the
linkers for SD l2 and SDL mixer so we
need to tell to use SDL to dial i'm SDL
to main dot live and then SDL to
underscore mixer dot live apply those
so that's everything with the properties
back up and double-check if you need to
okay let's get to building these
functions so let's think about what we
want to do exactly first so let's go to
our main and let's assume that yes we
want to include our sound effects H so
we're going to be using that and it's an
object just called SDL two sound effects
and we're going to shade it and we'll
just call it SC or sound effects and so
if you think about this what would you
ideally want to do as a from a
programmatic perspective interface in a
class I'm thinking we just want to do
something like we want to have a
function called add sound effect and
maybe it has a path maybe we want to SC
play sound and the sound could be just a
number so for the plane sound well I
have some sound effects on my hard drive
you can use any WAV or mp3 file i've
custom made some well sort of custom so
i'm going to paste in a path here this
just goes to one of my drop boxes and it
has an RTD to little talk thing and
maybe I'd also want to load a second
sound because in theory I'd be able to
like to be able to load up several
different sound effects so here's a
second one that is a grunt sound effect
I think I'm gonna change that because
that particular grunt sound effect is
not what you would expect it's like
three minutes of grunting don't judge me
it's okay here's a bunch of other random
ones I could just I want to use a small
one to that grunt sound effect is like a
giant let's just use Metal Gear Solid
alert so I want to click on this hit f2
press ctrl C to copy that and I'm just
gonna put this in here
Todd mp3 is right so we go back to this
we could we could grab more of these and
we could copy this line and place this
in here your dead sound effect and we
could just keep doing this is the idea
and then eventually we'll want to play
them and to do that if we return 0 and
right after playing it you won't hear it
because the sound will be gone so let's
make a little loop that has a choice
variable so while and we'll say the
choice is not equal to negative 1 we'll
stay in the loop and then we can do
something like well it started out by
just making sure it's 0 every new loop
and we'll ask the user for something
which sound effect to play enter
negative 1 to exit I know this is a
super long line at this point so we can
make it a little nicer by putting a new
line here and continuing our see out
with like a thing here that prompts we
could we could do anything whatever
whatever you want to do and to prompt is
fine so yeah and then we'll end that and
then we want to take in their number so
CN choice and obviously I need to
include these this I oh stream for that
and then I guess after we get the choice
we want to do like sound effect not play
sound effect and whatever choice and
then in case they gave us some bad stuff
let's do a C and clear I don't know
that's not going to be perfect but it'll
solve some weird errors if like a user
presses a lot of buttons C and up clear
doesn't clear all this but it'll help in
some cases this isn't a perfect thing
because well the end user can mess it up
like if you enter valid choices all the
time it'll be fine but if you just like
press a million buttons and for this who
knows what's gonna do it'll probably go
a little crazy all right well we got
three sound effects we just need to
build our class to accept these and this
is where we get into all the SDL to
stuff so let's look at the header we
need some public and private stuff let's
see privately we're going to want all
our sounds so we're gonna want them in a
vector cuz there's going to be a bunch
of them and this just Auto did this stop
we're gonna be using a mixed junk and
we'll just call this our sound effect
Bank now once it doesn't understand
vector because we got to include it
that's fine doesn't understand mix chunk
because that's part of STL 2 which it
doesn't seem to see through the audio so
let's just include it manually include
STL - oh it's STL - mixer yes I could
just look so let's go to the mixer to
the includes underscore SDL underscore
mixer that's what we want there that
should be happy yes so there we have our
mix chunk available and we're gonna do
of course a constructor just a default
one that's gonna initialize STL and
we'll do a destructor and this will just
de initialize STL for now okay I got it
I need a 2 in here there we go now
they're happy and we want our functions
that we preemptively tried to use before
building them and sound the fact it's
not what I call it sound effect yeah
that sound effect and then play sound
effect okay and this is going to take a
care star actually it's going to be a
Const cast R of a
it's basically a string in a more raw
format since this constant can be
changed that's what these quotations
default to so that's why I'm doing that
you can use strings if you want and then
play sound effect and we'll say which
this should also be Const now these
aren't going to be perfect there is room
for improvement so if you have any feel
free to note it below and maybe I'll
consider adding it in on the next part
of this what I can as I continue making
these sorts of videos we can press alt
enter to have it do it so Auto thing of
generating these functions but I just
want to create all four of them over
here in my object file so now I can
build these out so when this starts we
want to initialize the sound and it
sound we're gonna do that with SDL init
and SDL and it audio cuz that's the only
part of SDL we want to initialize here
and I believe SDL an int is actually
part of SDL yeah there we go so that's
part of where we start to need the SDL
header okay and then we're basically
going to do mix open audio and give it
all these rates frequency format channel
chunk size and so we can change those if
we want I'm just gonna go ahead and
paste them up here but since we're doing
a class these would probably end up
being member variables in the long run
that way we could set them up however we
wanted but for now I'm just going to
initialize it and then these variables
are gone so there it initializes now
this returned something
look at the signature turns returns an
int and so we want to store that in to
make sure that this initialize properly
we can do it like that we can also just
check it right within a statement itself
sort of like so and when we just want to
be sure that it's not equal to zero
because if it equals or I'm sorry I'm
saying this backwards we want to be sure
it equals zero so just putting it in the
if statement like this we'll execute it
it's not equal to zero we go inside this
tip statement and this is just going to
be an error statement so I'm gonna put
this standard log error which is just
like so and we will exit the application
if said thing happens that way we don't
bug anything out by continuing further
so that will initialize the sound and
also at the same time make sure it
doesn't error out and when we exit this
class we are going to do SDL quit for
now because we are all done with STL
it's the only thing in our project with
it and now the add sound effect so
basically what we want to do here is
take that path and load up a new mix
chunk so we're going to declare up mix
chunk pointer we'll just call it
Timm Timm chunk and we'll do may explode
wave which is part of STL mixer and
we'll do it on the path so it'll attempt
to load the wave at that path also works
for mp3s despite it being named load
wave so then from here we can just check
and make sure that this chunk actually
initialized make sure it's not equal to
null pointer so we'll do it this this
way yeah if it's not equal to null
pointer then we have a success but we
have a success and we want to go ahead
and add it to our sound Bank so we push
that temp chunk on door sound Bank and
we're all good now we could add a little
message here
this will just tell us how big our sound
Bank is as we continue to load more and
more because it's going off the sound
bank size and I'll tell you which one
will say it'll say like the first one
will say 0 sound is ready and then I
could say something like path and then
we'll show up the path so they know
which one it is ok so every time you
load a sound it'll just tell you on the
command line which one it is that way we
can work with the little playback thing
a little better alright and went in for
the plane sound we basically want to
well before we get to that let's go
ahead and do the error case here and
it's just going to be the same thing as
this above we don't want to exit though
it just won't get added to our bank
because it will go to this instead of
adding into our bank then I think that's
all we need to do ok now when we want to
play the sound we will just want to call
this one and which is going to be which
sound to play basically out of these
numbers from the size so first thing
we're going to do is just check and make
sure it's within range so if the number
we put in is greater then the range
allowed we'll just let them know sound
out of range then we could give them a
little more info
but that's all we're gonna do for now
well we will put a new line there and if
it's not on a range we'll just it just
skips over and we continue so that way
we know it's a valid play attempt
negative 1 is which channel that just
says the first available channel sound
effect Bank at which is which sound
effect and 0 to play it just a single
time we could put another last note that
we just played a sound here played sound
and I guess we'll just put the number
here that's good enough for now
and now this should all work so let's
just make sure everything's saved here
saved and we'll go over to our main
looks like we're good here
it's gonna load these three sounds well
it's going to stand shoot our class load
these three sounds and we'll get
messages about all three of them and
then we'll be able to it'll start this
loop and sit at this prompt and we can
enter in a number to play into this
house and it should it should just work
closer let's go ahead and play here
it's my output there we go it looks like
it didn't find SDL two DLL which is
weird because it's right here now I
think maybe these aren't linked as
expected let's go ahead and exclude them
from the project yeah that copy and
paste thing I said earlier don't do that
sorry
instead go to your project path and go
to open folder and file explorer so you
want to just find where you major your
project and just paste them in here
because what that paste was doing when I
was paste in the solution Explorer is I
think it was just making a some kind of
oh what are they called
someone will know in the comments
probably but I think it's a dynamic link
like the object wasn't actually there it
was just referencing it and that's not
enough for these runtimes they need to
actually be there so let's go back to
these back to the Live 64 and we'll grab
all these same ones hit copy ctrl C and
go to our and you go into the project
that it is so you go one level deeper
and then you paste those and we're gonna
do the same thing with the library for a
steal the dll here copy paste now
they're over here so if we hit refresh
over here we should see them all pop up
there they are very good and now this
should work okay very good
so zero sound is ready it came from that
path one sound is ready came from that
path two sounds ready which sound effect
to play or one negative one to exit so
let's go ahead and just press right down
the line zero one they don't cure solid
alert I love it
okay you are dead sound effect this is a
scream fair warning so we could in
theory add as many as we want and this
Bank will just keep keep adding more and
we can play them just with this little
loop but of course you can use them as
you want in logic with your own program
or great game alright that's gonna do it
thank you very much for watching I hope
you enjoy it or learn something and can
get this code all running wish you luck
in all your endeavors this has been Matt
from code tech and tutorials I'll see
you guys in the next video peace out